el acuerdo para exportar granos
ucranianos a través del mar Negro fue
extendido por dos meses más la noticia
se conoció un día antes de que expirar
el pacto hoy 18 de mayo y en medio de
las amenazas de Rusia de no renovarlo
para analizar este tema saludamos en
Barcelona a Miguel Medina él Es doctor
en relaciones internacionales por la
universidad de Cambridge y consultor en
asuntos europeos e internacionales señor
Medina Bienvenido a directo América
Buenos días buenas tardes para mí Buenos
días para vosotros Muy buenas tardes
para usted lo hablamos al principio de
la guerra pero vale la pena retomar la
discusión teniendo en cuenta la
coyuntura del acuerdo Por qué es
importante este pacto de exportación
Porque es importante garantizar el envío
de granos desde Ucrania
bueno digamos desde una perspectiva
global sobre todo seguir garantizando la
seguridad alimentaria global los flujos
de suministro digamos el abastecimiento
sobre todo a grandes partes del mundo
china economías asiáticas Europa y
África en segundo lugar porque porque se
ve que se puede negociar con Rusia y que
hay atisbos de Esperanza digamos en este
sentido y En tercer lugar yo pondría de
manifiesto digamos que estamos ante los
dos de los meses más fértiles del año
digamos en lo que es cosecha y
exportación de cereales no solo trigos y
también maíz y cebada con lo cual es muy
buena noticia porque el general invierno
ya ha pasado con lo cual digamos los
problemas de seguridad alimentaria que
pueden venir provocados por otra crisis
de la exportación del grano digamos
parece que por lo menos toman un respiro
Parece que la primavera nos trae buenas
noticias en este sentido y en cuarto
lugar esto refuerza un poco para perder
la comunidad internacional digamos que
con el con el sello de tres de Naciones
Unidas y la punta del iceberg de Turquía
que investigador de este acuerdo digamos
hay brotes verdes en cuanto a las
soluciones de conflicto se refiere ahora
que va a pasar Si eventualmente deja de
prorrogarse este acuerdo por ejemplo
tendría el mismo impacto que tuvo al
inicio de la guerra cuando se hablaba
por ejemplo de una crisis alimentaria yo
creo que no yo creo que a corto plazo
tendría el efecto inmediato de que te
diría cualquier economista va a subir el
precio porque va a bajar la oferta
digamos con lo cual la demanda va a
seguir igual con lo cual sube el precio
pero a largo plazo yo no creo que
tuvieron un impacto de pan no de
pandemia sino de crisis global o de
afectación global como tú hace un año
tres meses primero el efecto sorpresa de
Putin ya se le ha acabado O sea yo no
puedo sorprender al mundo con la con
vetar la exportación de trigo por el mar
Negro Y en segundo lugar tanto la
comunidad internacional como la Unión
Europea en particular se han puesto
manos a la obra en cuanto a
diversificación digamos de exportación
de granos se refiere la importancia de
la exportación de grano ucraniano No se
puede digamos por por el producto bruto
por la parte del mercado que tiene
Ucrania pero si las fuentes tanto de
importación como de exportación con lo
cual volviendo la pregunta yo creo que a
primer impacto sería una subida del
precio inmediata pero no serían
problemas de desabastecimiento a nivel
global y solamente provocaría el efecto
contrario que sería a seguir aumentando
la diversificación tanto de exportación
como de importación digamos de fuentes
de de grano hablamos sobre todo de trigo
de maíz y de cebada ahora por otro lado
se habla también de que se pronostica
una una caída en la en la exportación de
granos desde Ucrania ya que los
agricultores redujeron sus operaciones
de cultivo y Por ende también la
producción debido al inicio de la guerra
se está buscando se están buscando otras
opciones Tal vez sí sí digamos ya hay
países hay economías asiáticas y algunos
africanas más en desarrollo digamos que
están buscando intentar no llegar a la
autosuficiencia en la producción
alimentaria de trigo y de y de sobre
todo de maíz que son los dos que ellos
más importan pero sí digamos
diversificar las fuerzas de importación
aquí donde juega más papel o quien juega
más Pérez la Unión Europea que
recordemos Ucrania es el granero de
Europa del mundo pero hay más países
agrícolas que con esta situación pueden
aumentar digamos la exportación de grano
al mundo no pueden sustituir a Ucrania
por la parte del pastel que se lleva
Ucrania pero sí que pueden ayudar a
mitigar los efectos digamos del
conflicto geopolítico entre Rusia y
Ucrania con lo cual lo que está haciendo
la comunidad internacional y la Unión
Europea en Aceros uñas se han dado
cuenta de esto que es que no se puede
depender en el exceso de un país que
exporta una gran parte de un producto
por muy Aliado que sea ese país con lo
cual yo creo que volviendo a la pregunta
anterior el efecto sorpresa no sería
tanto y sobre todo la gran la gran idea
en este sentido de la comunidad
internacional es diversificar tanto la
exportación aquí la Unión Europea juega
mucho papel como la importación y en
este caso algunos países en África y
muchas economías asiáticas están
intentando no el autoabastecimiento en
términos agrícolas pero sí digamos
diversificar las fuentes que utilizan
para su crecimiento económico para
pesticidas para fertilizantes etcétera
etcétera muy rápidamente porque estas
exportaciones dependen exclusivamente en
gran parte de la vía marítima por
ejemplo que desafíos logísticos se
enfrentan al intentar exportar estos
granos por tierra por ejemplo en las
fronteras con Europa Sí pues bueno
primero diría una dinámica del sistema
internacional que históricamente el 80%
del comercio mundial es marítimo con lo
cual romper esta dinámica simplemente o
a raíz de un conflicto geopolítico entre
los países es muy difícil segundo la
capacidad de cargamento marítimo es
mucho más mayor que la terrestre
tercero por el mar y navegando en aguas
internacionales se evitan conflictos y
se evitan fronteras terrestres y y se
evitan digamos dinámicas geopolíticas
que de otra manera no Se podrían imitar
Claro si uno mira el mapa de Ucrania
Digamos si Mira hacia su este tiene
Bielorrusia tiene Rusia y después tiene
el cáucaso si mira al oeste tiene
moldavia tiene Polonia con lo cual
logísticamente aparte de problemas
ambientales y posibles problemas en
fronteras es Digamos como exportar de
una manera más sofisticada y más
logística todo el grano por eso la vía
marítima es la preferida
mirada Miguel Medina doctor en
relaciones internacionales por la
universidad de Cambridge Muchas gracias
por acompañarnos en este análisis aquí
en directo América un placer Buenas
tardes Buenos días para vosotros
igualmente y de esta manera terminamos
Este primer bloque de directo América
pero no se desconecten porque minutos
regresamos con más
[Música]